si vous avez un smartphone Samsung il y
a un tout nouveau widget qui vient de
faire son apparition avec One y5.1 c'est
vachement cool regardez vous appuyez là
vous allez dans widget et vous venez le
chercher dans batterie donc là vous
aurez les niveaux de batterie de vos
appareils alors vous pouvez l'avoir soit
au format 4 x 1 soit au format 4 x 2 et
ça va venir afficher directement tous
vos widgets alors moi ici je vais avoir
uniquement mon S Pen je vais avoir
uniquement mon smartphone mais si vous
avez des Galaxy buzz et bien vous aurez
le niveau de batterie de vos Galaxy buds
si vous avez une galaxie watch vous
aurez le niveau de batterie de votre
Galaxy watch je trouve ça très chouette
très mal un très pratique c'est très
bien que ça me saoule soit venu de
mettre d'ailleurs dites-moi ce que vous
en pensez dans les commentaires est-ce
que ça peut vous intéresser oui ou non
marquez moi ça